foreign
[Music]
ing
it's Super Bowl week and we got the
legend man Calvin Johnson on the show to
help build our Super Bowl parlay so
start now start using those fingers drop
your picks in the chat Calvin uh I don't
know about you but I know at my
household Super Bowl Sunday it's a day
that we we all get together we all bring
our finest dishes and we celebrate
football man so I got to start this off
with what's your favorite Super Bowl
food
[Music]
um
I gotta have a buffalo chicken dip
and a variety of chips
buffalo chicken dip and I mean every
every Super Bowl got to have is is
Buffalo and lemon pepper wings if not
mixed together the same sauces are you
uh are you a pita chip guy I feel like
that's the distinction in chip is
important you know my my wife my wife
does have me on pita chips you know
Peter chips is new to me I'm from
Georgia you know but being up here in
Michigan there is a heavy Middle Eastern
presence and pita chips you know they
have the thing up here and I have
actually fell in love with them
especially when they're fresh they are
very good yes
huge no he's right the second I tried
him I felt I was in love I was in love
so
it's Super Bowl week so welcome to the
show we got NFL Hall of Famer Calvin
Johnson here to help build our Super
Bowl parlay Megatron welcome to the show
have you ever built a Super Bowl parlay
or will this be your first one
this will be my first one so I'm looking
forward to building it with you guys
here y'all y'all gonna help me out hook
me up
yeah so let me let me explain it to you
a little bit what we do around here is
we ask the audience for winners and then
we build a parlay you know we we debate
we talk about it we talk about it with
them we build a parlay does that sound
good to you Megatron
sounds wonderful
all right Ryan tell the people what we
need from them well we need your locks
first of all that's it's the most
important thing here because we want to
win right but I think we should start
off with anytime t-day how do you guys
feel about that who's scoring a
touchdown
let's do it all right so we need the we
need takes from the chat uh Calvin I
will say in week one uh you put me on to
DeAndre Swift two plus touchdowns uh
that did not hit Greg knows I'm not and
I Told You So guys but I would just like
to say is your opportunity for
Redemption
big I Told You So guy below you Calvin
just just give you the heads up right
now I feel it I can feel it oh okay all
right this is how we're starting already
all right uh M Menino says Travis Kelsey
anytime touchdown we see that here
that's minus 110. what do you guys think
I like it I I like Travis Kelsey I I I
don't know why I like I think Jalen
hurts is easier than Travis Kelsey even
though I think the Chiefs win yeah I
just think that Jalen hurts and is that
plus money Ryan is my eyes deceiving me
or that's plus 100 right yeah that's
that's PL that's plus 100 we also have
facts left in here saying miles Sanders
anytime touchdown plus 125. Calvin do
you have before we before we dive into
the chat do you have a lien on who you
think is going to score
um I was gonna go with Jalen 100 that
would have been my first pick would have
been Jaylen hurts okay we got highest
odds in here saying Jalen anytime TD is
a lock in all caps
we could just go with that I mean we see
what they do we see what they do
especially when they get that you know
that bunched that Bunch formation and
they pushed but Jalen hurts yeah
yeah I saw it a lot the other the other
day right you know about that my 49ers
so yeah yeah yeah it still hurts still
hurts I bet it does uh we can uh we get
we'll lock in Jalen hurt so we get we
start off with some plus money you know
that's my that is that was my favorite
kind of BET
I I like that a lot
Calvin what's your take on Jalen hurts
what's your what's your take on him you
like him
man I love doing hers man I love
Jennifer since she was in Alabama you
know he went through his his struggle
there in the dang championship game when
they put two in and he transferred to
Oklahoma you know he kept his uh his
demeanor the same kept pushing for
trying to put you know become the
greatest version of himself you know
that's how I mean that's why I love the
kid because every everywhere he goes you
know he rises to the top so um you know
expect nothing less here and that's who
we are starting our parlay off with but
every receiver needs a quarterback
that's why I can see the connection he
liking Jalen hurts but we have one of
the best receivers in the history in the
building so we need some receiver props
Ryan we need some receiver props let's
start with the Chiefs
let's do it uh well we need the help of
the chat a little bit here the chat
needs to start Chad needs she needs to
put the show on the back on their back
right now
um but we've got we could do Juju Smith
we can do Kadarius Tony
I think we would be foolish to not do
something with Travis Kelsey but that's
just my take
um I don't know the the chat loves
Travis Kelsey in this game yeah so I see
Oliver marks in the chest saying Travis
Kelsey anytime touchdown shout out to
you Oliver marks uh oh interesting one
here look Calvin please please indulge
here uh jeric McKinnon even though he's
not a wide receiver but they set a
receiving touchdown
Jeremy Ken is always good for that swing
out the backfield but it's hard not to
go with uh Travis Kelsey I mean Ryan
mentioned it on the last on the line on
the first one you know Travis Kelsey
would have been my second pick there
because he goes off in all big games you
know so I would you know I'll expect to
see uh him in the end zone as well today
or should I said today Sunday Calvin
pushing my agenda this is where have you
been all season man this is the support
I owe you one I know you do thank you I
appreciate it I was gonna say but I'm
glad you did uh 74 and a half yards uh
so you like that over you would do over
74 and a half yards
we could do 64 and a half if we want to
tease it down
yeah
I mean if I I said he goes off but dang
I mean for tight end going off for 74 is
a big game yeah
um 65 64 is much more tense like two
passes potentially let's go for 74. he
needs to have a big game for them to win
74 74 Travis Nelson Michael
but I think I mean 64 be a safer bet
okay it would be a safer back inside
against that eagle defense you know I
got slay back there
I'm gonna tell you about my friend below
he's Ryan he he likes to push his agenda
so he comes into the shows with vets
already brewed in his head and so he
tries to he tries to swing you his way
you know what I'm saying so it's working
64. don't let him don't let them take
you up to 74. if you fill in that 64
number
the more reasonable thing to do would be
64. let's do it let's do it Michael Fray
in the chat here's with you he said
Kelsey over 64. so I like that I think
we're feeling good
let's let's move let's move on let's
move what's next right I'm not swim as
much anymore yeah no no we're feeling
good we're feeling good what's next are
we uh are we still touching receivers
yeah we got to go to the Eagles side and
I think we know I think I think I know
who I like over there
what do we think Calvin
what they got for AJ Brown over there
what's up that's the man we're talking
about here we got 59 yards minus 185 if
we go over that
that's the lowest we can go with we've
got it we've got a range here yeah I
need I need AJ to go over 85 I mean 59
goodness gracious yeah
we can also do Devonta Smith he could
get that in Yak
you can get that on one catch literally
yeah
literally but yeah
Devonte and and AJ to go over on 60.
for 59 and a half yeah
uh Devonta is more of a more of your
your deep threat guy a guy that you
could probably get some of these yards
let's see he's at 49ers
AJ's got to touch the ball at least like
six seven times this game right he does
that comments touches the ball that many
times she's going to get
60 70 yards
during 85 is saying take the Devonta
Smith over uh tjf is also telling us to
take Devonta Smith but but hold on hold
on hold on we got live from the 215.
shout out to the 215. they said AJ Brown
they like AJ Brown in his receiving
yards this is a tough one this is a
tough one I will also say Greg big
Chewie 13 in the chat great username
almost made me chuckle uh AJ Brown
reception's over is a lock I don't know
if we want to do receptions if we just
want to keep it to yards
but he's got to get he's got to get fed
well we we got one of the greatest
receivers in the in the history of NFL
so uh Calvin should we should we talk
receptions
yeah I mean I he has to I mean he has to
have over five he has to have a minimum
fire that's just like one a quarter
that's not even like getting your play
makers involved if they're getting him
involved he's gonna have a he's going to
have seven plus
oh so you're taking seven are you
thinking five plus or you think it's
seven plus here because the chat's now
all in on AJ Brown reception so now it's
just a matter of what number
I want seven I want him to have nine you
know but yeah he's gotta have five if he
doesn't have five if he don't have five
receptions then they don't deserve to
win the game to win the game that's yup
I love this call right there I love this
energy that is a good call that's hey
that's why we got you know that's why we
got Calvin here man to you know Steer Us
in the right direction not you Ryan
that's that's not he's a Hall of Famer
listen I'm loving this from Calvin
because the amount of times I've also
thought like oh no way he can't have
five like right like there's it's
impossible he has to have five and then
it doesn't hit so I'm not rooting for it
not to hit but you'll also you'll also
understand some of the frustration here
so hey you're understanding you're for
sure hear him uh Calvin but Ryan let's
talk about uh what's next we talked we
talked receiving for the Chiefs we
talked to receiving for the eagles which
way are we going next it's got to be QB
props can be either one
Pat Mahomes Jalen hurts what a week ago
passing yards we can go uh I believe
like passing touchdowns
I feel like we gotta sprinkle a pat
property here we got Jalen hurts to
score yeah you know we know Pat goes
show up let me see what they talking
about in the comments though
um I see Pat homes two touchdowns okay
um
what you like from Pat Ryan push your
agenda because I know I know you want to
yeah you know I always want to I think
oh man
I I feel for some reason I feel more
confident in yards than I do touchdowns
I take touchdowns the lowest we can go
would be two plus I feel like that's
slightly a big ask
um for to be on the lower side like I
feel like him getting over 249 passing
yards
yeah absolutely a given I think so uh we
we saw we saw with I don't know if you
guys saw but Debo Samuel got interviewed
earlier today and he he said the way to
attack this Eagles defense is on the
back end don't try to go against that
d-line or try to attack them on the back
end and nobody better nobody better to
attack them on the back end and Patrick
Mahomes but but before we lock this in
Calvin I want to talk to you because we
have to talk about the ankle we have to
you experience injuries in the NFL he
had two weeks to recover
do you think it can be I wouldn't say a
hundred but somewhere close to 80.
75 Maybe
I mean what do you have a high ankle
sprain
yeah what grade what grade was it
oh
Ryan you want to research that depending
on the grade depending on the grade of
the high angle spray and I think they'd
never be like a broken angle I had one
and they I mean they say four weeks four
but I mean you really need you know six
seven weeks before you're really really
feeling good you know really about
pushing off of that thing fortunately
he's not running routes you know
unfortunately he's just dropping back
still you got to stick that foot in the
ground is it his uh plant foot I don't I
don't recall which foot it is which
anklewood is that makes a big difference
too
yeah if it's your plant foot
unfortunately that's right at the
beginning of the game you know you got
your juices going the adrenaline rush
and you know so you you probably shot up
and everything but that's the course of
that game goes on and the more and more
you stick in that flip in the ground you
know it's going to wear it it's going to
wear and tear on you but it all depends
on the grade of the spring it all
depends on how bad it was because he
hasn't had he's had he has had some time
to be off of it
Michael Frey in the comments Calvin I
just want you to hear from a Fan's
perspective he said the ankle is fully
healed I don't know about that one
yeah
it's funny to hear The Wishful thinker
but Ryan man let's let's dive back in I
like Pat Mahomes I I think he's gonna
you know I don't know I don't want to
speculate maybe get a shot and and I
don't know something some definitely go
get some treatment on the ankle ain't
gonna go be feeling uh feeling okay for
him to go out there on Sunday but what
are we thinking did we see something in
the in the comments that caught our eye
yeah I mean Pat my home's a pretty
decent quarterback I think we can all
agree on that right uh it's uh it's his
right ankle so it would be it would be
his plant foot uh Sunny 238 says over
300 for my homes uh I saw from
I think it was I think it was Michael
Frey again jumping in here dropping all
the takes uh no it was Darian 85 who
said under 292 passing yards not against
that defense I can't remember if Dairy
and 85 is an Eagles fan or not but that
sounds like some Philadelphia propaganda
if I've ever heard of before
you know how these Philly fans are
Calvin and say you gotta I see you got a
Darius Slay Jersey back there don't
don't be don't yeah there you go block
that I don't need to see that right now
[Applause]
um I don't know let's see yeah there we
go we're trying to there it is there it
is uh
[Laughter]
I don't know I I'm I'm cool with doing
I'm cool with doing passing yards it's
minus 320 for a reason we have some
value already on the board and then
let's move on to it I say let's do the
over 249 and then we can move into a uh
a rushing
oh wow wow Ryan you're only going over
249 here
I just feel like it's it's in the bank
if we do that we're at oh wow wow now
we're at plus 370. I don't love that but
I don't know you
I think it's I think I think that this
is a guarantee that's my take and I
don't think we have enough guarantees on
the board I feel like 300 is a guarantee
300. Calvin what do you mean
300 means I guess he's walking out of
here with the MVP you know he just added
to his collection you know yeah upon the
legend with the sprained ankle you know
that's what 300 means I feel in my mind
300 that means they're walking out there
with a w
what if we meet in the middle do over
274 and a half
yeah let's do that yeah do we feel good
about that Calvin
I don't feel like it was more I I agree
with you I thought it was a lock at 249
because it's just that defense that
d-line they got a pretty decent
secondary I mean that's the main thing
let's make this should we make this to
Calvin parlay just go to 249 and a half
now
Calvin I I will remind you if this if
this parlay doesn't hit a lot of these
pictures
a lot of these picks are yours
[Laughter]
I'm confident all right all right let's
do over 249. let's do it let's do it
lock it in all right uh rushing yards
what do we want to do here
this is time that's tough one this one
is tough gamewell's been he's been uh
he's been springy for the Eagles
this playoffs
I feel like yeah I feel like somebody's
gonna rip one off for the Eagles it's
just a matter of who
hmm
Boston Scott miles Sanders
Kenneth gainwell we can even do Jalen
hurts dare I say do we do Patrick
Mahomes with the ankle
is he is he listed
uh
uh he's not oh yes he is yes he is
but that's a lot 15 plus for a
quarterback with a bad ankle sprain
feels like a lot
I don't I don't think that's that bad
because he's going he's probably going
to get flushed out the pocket during
this game when he drops back I think
he's going to get flushed is he going to
have a chance to turn that into some
yardage potentially
I don't hate the take I just think if
we're doing his passing yards over and
that we're we're all in we're all in on
Pat Mahomes it's my which is not a bad
place to be it's just it's a little
risky
you're right I don't think so you don't
think so
the chat loves you know why though you
you know yeah yeah Greg's pushing his
Chiefs propaganda right now this is I
don't need to hear this uh we've got a
lot of love for Isaiah Pacheco in the
chat uh
go ahead and rechia says Pacheco Michael
bowling says Pacheco
I see love for my man game will as well
Ryan I see G villy gamewell 15 plus is a
lot G Smith 813 game will over 24 and a
half is a lock
see see guys like gamewell it only takes
one
it just takes once
spring and then he's like 15 yards down
the field
what
why again my concern and this is just me
speaking out my anxiety here is he is a
backup running back so there's a chance
that he does he gets limited
opportunities and in those opportunities
he doesn't
take advantage the way we need him to
well Ryan have you been paying attention
to how the Eagles
you were watching I was I was watching
with you how the Eagles been using him
this playoffs though he's been there
he's been there springy backed his
playoffs and I don't think that they're
gonna change that going into this game
oh the Eagles play volleyball no doubt
but I guess Calvin I I look for your
thoughts on like we could do gainwell we
could do Sanders we can even do Jalen
hurts so I I guess I'm just
looking for your Insight
that's
oh man I like gamewell because he's been
on my radar all playoffs every time I
looked up I'm like who is this guy who
who's this little guy just like Darton
and just making 10 yard games every time
I touch the ball
um so him at uh yeah I can definitely
see him
over 100 percent I mean 14 I think 15 is
like that's
it's Child's Place
yeah that's what I'm saying Calvin
that's like one two carries for him man
Calvin you should be a Salesman this is
every one of these that you've said is
this should be a lock so I feel pretty
good this is pretty solid list right
here yeah if I show this to my
brother-in-law he's on here all the time
he might take that yeah
so Calvin are we locking it in
this would be if you put in a hundred
bucks
get 500.
Plus 500.
foreign
yeah
there it is there it is that's the
official Megatron big game parlay tell
us on drag DraftKings and if you are a
new customer Ryan tell the people what's
happening
it's a great deal I wish that I was a
new customer because you bet five bucks
boom you're getting 200 in bonus bets
just like that 200 bucks to maybe bet on
Super Bowl MVP maybe to bet on a certain
money line either way we'll get to that
in a second but 200 is a bonus bets well
it gets better than that so if you're a
new customer Place five bucks get 200
back and boom
there you go there it is there it is get
your money back now Calvin let's talk
some more of your Best Bets everybody
likes the coin toss a lot of people be
betting on the coin toss it's that
adrenaline of uh you know starting the
Super Bowl off right you could either
start off happy or you can start off sad
but let's talk about the coin toss uh
talk about it are you a heads or tails
guy
I was always a Tails guy
I always I don't think I ever call ahead
even when I was a captain I always
called Tails Tails never fails Tails
never fails yeah yeah it's a True
Believer and the tales never fails now
uh
real quick how many how many heads guys
do you actually know
are there a lot of them out there are
there a collection of them is there a
group of them
you know I get ponytails you barely hear
the guys when they say heads you know
they kind of whisper it
when they say it they're like damn it's
Gonna Be Tails yeah they're afraid to
even say it I got you yeah
another thing a lot of people likes to
put their money on Calvin is the
Gatorade color the Gatorade color that
you know that they pour the culture you
know what I'm saying yeah that one so uh
let's talk about it what's your favorite
Gatorade to drink because I'm a cool
blue guy I I'm a cool blue I like the
blue blue I love everything blue
everything blue and I was gonna say blue
and I was like I wanna yeah yeah
can be oral just like that's the old
school blue
guys it's cool blue so if you're looking
if you're you're in the grocery store
and you have every Gatorade available to
you you're picking blue
yeah
you have a blue black background no it
doesn't mean I drink everything that's
blue
uh these are the options what are you
I'm curious what are you going with oh
huge yellow guy huge yellow girl I love
yellow Gatorade yellow yeah my favorite
color is also blue but again it just
because you plop Something Blue in front
of me doesn't mean that it's uh it's a
guarantee I'm drinking it just
letting everyone know
so uh who do you know who exactly picks
the Gatorade color Calvin
like is it a is it a Captain's Choice is
it like
hmm that's a good ass question
that's a good question I only ask good
questions Greg knows this I feel like I
should know that you know but you know
the funny thing is I I didn't drink I
drink like a water after my whole mix of
drink on the sideline but yeah
good question I have no idea on the
trainers now there we go that was going
to be my next question Calvin like on
the sideline does everybody have their
own drink or are you guys sharing like
how we did in Pop Warner in high school
you know when we all let me get some
water
yeah
bunch of community bottles that the
trainers just grabbed from and like
squirting everybody's mouth you know
it's kind of kind of rule don't put your
mouth on it like the water fountain but
um like some guys do have their own
their own
finish with
got you got you let's get to the let's
get to the nitty-gritty man let's get to
the nitty-gritty because we ain't talked
about it since uh we've been on the show
man Super Bowl winner Super Bowl winner
Calvin Johnson who do you have winning
the Super Bowl
this year
oh man
you gonna put me on the spot but it's
okay
[Laughter]
I knew that was back there for a big
play slave
and the Eagles I got some dogs over
there they got some dolls on that Squad
man I'm looking forward to seeing them
boys man I'm a big Jay the hurts fan I'm
a big fan of all the receivers they got
over there now all of them was from the
SEC so yeah yeah I love having home I
love them I love them but yeah
yeah time for the Eagles to fly
time for the eagle they just flew not
that long ago
seems way too excited to push this
Philadelphia propaganda I'm just letting
you know
hey he knows people over there Ryan you
you you wouldn't know what that's like
you know what I'm saying I think you
know even if I'd have slay over there
and Dom can sue I'm trying to think that
you know the guys I play with you know I
love AJ Brown I love hers I love Devonte
I mean I'm a big fan of SEC football so
I watched some boys when they're playing
in college and even now still making
plays and the added bonus I got my dogs
over there that I played with you know
in Detroit so I'll be happy to see them
he's rocking with his boys Ryan I don't
know I don't think you know anything
well about loyalty well he already had
one of his boys with a Super Bowl last
year with Matt Stafford I you know one
of your boys can't win every year Calvin
it's been like that the last couple of
years yeah that's what I'm saying
move on any receiver to win MVP
you think that there will be any
receivers to win MVP uh it's plus 650
100 wins 650 dollars
what do you think let's look is these
the odds right here yes sir wide
receiver to win MVP is Plus 650.
do you think any of these guys can go
get it done
AJ's feeling good
he's getting in he has like 50 yards to
get yeah
and five and five plus receptions don't
forget
okay
he gotta have five it's not even a
question
safe
is that the only receiver we can see
winning it
um I mean I I mean obviously Devonte but
I mean
uh
I mean what do y'all what you thinking I
mean we were talking about obviously we
were talking about uh Philly I mean kc2
but yeah but Juju with Travis no that's
tight end tight ends yeah
no I can't I can't really I think AJ's
probably the only one yeah I see yeah
he's my number one yeah yeah I agree
Devonta maybe that's like a wow wow wow
card I'd rather just bet him to win MVP
than this but did you say Juju that is
that what you said
I was just throwing it out there yeah
yeah don't let him forget he said that
don't let him he's throwing it out there
yeah
[Laughter]
all right hey man let's get real
realistic right here because uh we
talking MVP MVP of the Super Bowl
she's a quarterbacks award usually uh a
lot of people put money on this one too
Calvin talk to us who do you think is
winning MVP of the Super Bowl
my safe bet will obviously be uh Jalen
um but if I wanna
stretch a little bit
um
if I want to stretch a little bit uh
I'm gonna skip over
song
just a thought
just looking at the looking at the
numbers and knowing
Devonte is my number two
but that's that's right that's that's
fine that's reach
miles Sanders
because we have a big big day on the
ground
maybe Kenneth gained well for our parlay
that'd be tough I mean uh he's gonna get
some runs but he's not gonna be the
focus no
big big play slang gets toothpicks takes
one to the house was that enough for is
that enough for MVP in the Super Bowl oh
for sure for sure but I haven't seen my
home's doing two kicks like that
yeah that's true I don't really
happening
hey hey Calvin Rocco with his man is he
rocking with his boys I like it I like
it I Derek slay can get toothpaste get
one get one uh pick six
you know what I'm saying get a pick late
and then he can possibly lock it up I
don't know we'll see buddy
if that help beat that would be tough uh
it's time for Megatron
it's time for Megatron that would be
tough but I don't know Calvin Harris is
my number one Jalen hurts it would be my
lock
I know what happened
[Laughter]
100 and then uh if I had to go if I had
to reach I would say
I'll go miles
I don't I just don't see that happening
yeah I'm not feeling that I'm not
confident that
not for Megatron to grade some of y'all
bets he's trying to figure Mega trying
to Grace some of your best get in the
comments and drop your winners drop your
questions for Megatron we'll do our best
as him for you Ryan what are the people
saying uh well the first one from
um
Mac Max for Excel it's pointing out that
you said at the start of the Season that
the lions were going to get over six and
a half wins so this is your chance
Calvin to say I told you so but but you
don't seem like it I Told You So guy but
uh
[Laughter]
but they are plus three thousand to win
the Super bowl next year so you place
100 bucks on that you can win 3 000. how
do you feel about the Lions next year
are we think it's Super Bowl yeah I like
them but it's not Super Bowl I I do like
playoffs I like playoffs next year
um I expect them to have a big
off-season especially with free agency
but uh but I I do think they um they
Advance a little bit more actually
getting to the playoffs this year
um they're playing well under their
coach and I expect this is more of a
okay it's your baby steps guy
I am I I
there's nothing that said to me that I
needed one piece or two pieces is in
there in the Super Bowl they need a
couple more pieces of that yeah
okay
uh
yes facts left Justin Jefferson almost
got your record this past year
you're safe congratulations you're still
the man do you think anyone gets it next
year
uh I don't know how long did I do that
what year was that I had it in a decade
I got a decade under my belt that might
be that'd be cool if I do but uh
I really don't even know but um it's
yeah like I say they got an extra game
to do it so I mean in the last two years
guys have been has been real close so
it's probably just really a matter of
time especially as much as we're going
the ball
um and you we have guys just making this
you know extremely crazy plays with
their obviously with their hands on
their feet too
yeah yeah you got it in 2012 by the way
so
over a decade now
so yeah there you go
um all right I'm gonna need you to light
somebody up here because we got Justin
Timberlake who says Jason Kelsey scoring
his first touchdown in the Super Bowl
Chase and Kelsey the second one they
probably just got confused they probably
just mixed them up is that an honest
mistake no I said Jason Kelsey scored
his first TD ever that was the comment
scored or he said he's scoring us he's
going to score in the Super Bowl yeah
you know what
don't play into this
brother's on the other team and then
like two they would just be comedy if
that was like the go ahead touchdown or
something like that that would be comedy
but how come scored in the game he had
just scored to take the lead or
something and then they go back down and
Jason scores a touchdown Super Bowl is
that enough to give the MVP
foreign
has actually another Lions question uh
asking if asking about your relationship
with Alliance now
yeah
well it's getting better man um
I think we're moving in the right
direction speaking
um of uh you know one of the executive
Executives over there you know in a way
to you know want to get me back involved
and the way I'm in the relationship you
know so it's obviously it's another
thing it's baby steps you know but um I
do like the way that uh
there we go I got a question Calvin um
on a lighter note uh how many scripts
did you receive in your NFL career for
the you saw that on it on the internet
oh hey Foster got all he got and he got
it golly all messed up oh yeah I don't
know why he I got all y'all messed up
like that man he got everybody talking
about
like how was that possible to script the
NFL yeah come on man you don't know if
you're gonna make it out of the game
shoot
like I mean I was not gonna say live but
you almost
you never know you never know what can
happen in this sport so just saying
scripted yeah it's that's a little bit
of breach you you never know but the
unofficial uh
unofficial may be official script that
came out does have the Eagles winning so
your prediction is uh prediction is true
I guess
you know just you know just speaking it
into existence that's all
speaking of uh Anything Can Happen zibi
326 wants to know if you're coming back
next year so can we count on that
you're making your return I mean God
willing I'm coming back next year the
football no
Ryan let's review the Megatron parlay
before we get on up out of here yes sir
all right so we've got Jalen hurts
anytime touchdown scorer lock we've
already determined that over 64 and a
half receiving yards for Travis Kelsey
luck AJ Brown five plus receptions if he
does not get five plus receptions Calvin
said he would throw his glasses through
his television so let's remember that
there you go over 249 and a half passing
yards for Patrick Mahomes and then over
14 and a half rushing yards for Kenneth
gainwell five legs plus 500 the Megatron
big game parlay
screenshot screenshot it because I don't
want to repeat myself screenshot
a screenshot
there you go cool all right uh
make sure you guys tap into the happy
hour Ryan tell them about the happy hour
yeah so at 6 P.M every day you get to
find out what DraftKings is boosting
Monday it was Jalen hurts or miles
Sanders rushing TD boosted to plus 100
Tuesday was the first team to score
either side plus 150. I have no idea
what it is today no clue at all Calvin
maybe you know I have no idea but tune
in at 6 pm and figure it out
there it is make sure you guys tune in
to figure it out Calvin thank you so
much for being here the legend man
thinks it's nice seeing you again uh
we'll be back Super Bowl Sunday
3 P.M Eastern with another preview show
so tap in until then follow us on BR
betting my name is Greg Ivory next to me
is the man the legend Calvin Johnson uh
and next to him is producer Ryan we are
out of here peace
[Music]
foreign